we actually got another uh video to
debut
uh from from the album uh actual music
video too
a music video let's hear a dog damn we
straight
record studio now we like cot 107.
i'm big
[Music]
and she was like five foot something a
little rambunctious
dm's always getting flooded guys always
trying to offer
[Music]
but it still didn't matter cause she
left me on scene
that girl so bad so beautiful the way
she walked away she talked like a movie
roll
harder than wasabi on the sushi roll and
all the guys are in her dm's life
[Music]
the vocals
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
could you
this is
oh
[Music]
hey mom
that's my favorite song i think yeah
that's a great song that one the hannah
bear one's my favorite
oh hannah baron goes hard too oh wow
when chin hits that out drive all the
way to alabama i get chills
i appreciate it jim went in on those
vocals huh chan take us through that
if i go if i do vocals i'll go all the
way in for sure all the way in all the
way
you wrote those lyrics [ __ ] no i uh did
yeah
okay i'll go all right
dog how crazy is this little brows
entered a
white rapper only contest on cats and
now he's doing a whole album with us did
you hear the story of how like he
came to do that video i thought he met a
few at a aaa meeting or some [ __ ]
i actually went to go get chick-fil-a on
a sunday night didn't realize it was
sunday pulled up to the parking lot
realized everything was closed
decided to record a rap and that's how
it happened wow that's his origin story
right there
chick-fil-a is closed i'm an internal
white rapper contest
what a great song a lot of white rappers
start yeah that's how most start
frustration from chick-fil-a damn man
logic they all started like that this
chick-fil-a is closed about to show
these [ __ ]
and then he ended up living like blocks
from the studio yeah like he lives
dude and what we're saying is the guy is
a
[Music]
it's the king of stalker games